Norman Solomon offer author of a new
book called the power of Babel the
politician's dictionary of buzzwords
double-talk for every occasion as an
observer of political speech how do you
judge the ability of the two presidents
presidential candidates George Bush and
Bill Clinton in using language to
achieve each of their political goals
first George Bush well he's very good he
has a depth speech writers like Peggy
Noonan the words are calculated they're
crisp there's a rhythm to them we can
remember four years later about a
thousand points of light and these are
words that really stick with us so I
think he's got his rhetoric down
although there are limits to what
rhetoric can do when you're sinking Bill
Clinton he's really developed I think as
genre of rhetoric that places him in the
so called center and I think we saw in
New York at the Democratic convention
how that positioning involves some
traditional buzz words and elevates some
new ones like responsibility responsible
behavior and there's some problems with
that but certainly it's adept in terms
of winning votes in the short run do you
distinguish between the formal prepared
texts such as an inaugural address in
your book and in your discussion and in
your study and then the stump speeches
well there are off-the-cuff speeches
that are more of course informal and so
forth but in a sense I'm not sure that
there are any major addresses or even
appearances by an ideal candidate
according to the handlers where someone
would wander off and improvise I mean
that's considered dangerous if you think
while you're talking in advance then
your thinking may cause you some
problems in other words one of the goals
of political language in the
manipulation of words by politicians is
to preempt and precede thought by the
voters they're trying to interfere
generally with a precision so that
instead of understanding what a
politician stands for or what the
constituents are who is paying the
politician there's a there's a vague
haze and in that sense a politician is
usually trying to be very ambiguous even
while also attempting to sound very
forthright we should tell the audience
that the book which you've just showed
you is out brand new it's in paperback
there's no hardback version and it is
truly it's in a dictionary format with
phrases in alphabetical order and we'll
go through a few give you an idea of
what's in here but I have to ask you why
did you think this book had to be
written even with all of the commercials
and the slick productions and image
making
I think words are still the staple of
the political diet that's what that's
what's fed to us or force-fed to us and
unless we can in a sense develop our
personal and social radar screens to
detect unidentified flying buzzwords you
might say then we're going to continue
to be victimized by this double-talk and
so the words in a sense the hot air has
to be deconstructed as it rises from the
teleprompters as it comes across the
airwaves unless we can discern what the
hidden agendas are behind the buzzwords
were in big trouble which i think is a
good description of the political
landscape right now we want to give the
audience a few examples of what we're
talking about before we go to the phones
and we will but in the meantime we put
the numbers up on the screen you can
begin dialing now there's a little bit
of space available for you to get in in
the subject is political speech and
that's a big subject so it'd be
interesting to see what people think
about not only the speeches they're
hearing now but what they've heard over
their political lives and whether
there's been an evolution we might get
to that but in the introduction you
offer some samples and I must say
wouldn't you characterize this as a
little bit tongue-in-cheek well it's a
condensation usually we get these kind
of buzzwords diluted and we don't
recognize how absurd they are and how
they don't really say anything except
often pander to prejudice let me give
people something to work with and then
you can talk about it and this is I
guess a buzzwords Laden speech you
describe it as a combative statement
given by politician X America bashing
and anti Western appeasement may appeal
to atheists but such backroom bankruptcy
is barbaric bean-counting inside the
beltway where big brother is big
government with a
Mic Check boys on the bus don't seem to
mind the breakdown of the family with
debris and white wine set and their
burdensome budgets a bureaucracy of
cheap-shot CLAT cheap-shot class
conflict is fueling costly cradle to
grave criminality the demagoguery is
divisive doom and gloom feds promote a
feeding frenzy aided by flimflammers
flip-flops heard journalist ideologues
and influence peddlers and you go on
what is a boy on the bus well that's
jargon for politicians who are used by
politicians to describe journalists who
are covering their campaigns it's
usually derisive where did you get all
of this well I really just read speeches
I spent a lot of last year gnashing my
teeth reading thousands of speeches by
politicians past and present I can't say
I was looking forward to the 92 campaign
but I knew it would come around just
like the calendar and I felt that we
needed to be able to in a sense for arm
ourselves be aware of what would come at
us in large quantities as indeed it has
this year that is a little sample speech
a little sound bite that is alphabetized
for easy reference and it just draws on
many of the buzz phrases in here when
you hear that there's a rhythm there's a
momentum to it and you're encouraged to
forget that there are lives in the
balance every time the government acts
or does not act on an issue and right
now we have a tremendous amount of
suffering in this country because of the
economy because of unequal opportunity
and yet this is the kind of babbling
that we get on a routine basis do you
think that the work well obviously you
do but some people wonder if words even
matter it's the ideas that matter well
words matter tremendously before a
politician is able to as an office
holder
implement policies that will cause the
deaths of people in Iraq or in South
Central Los Angeles or in rural areas of
this country where poverty is still very
severe language has to be in a sense
damaged or even killed and when language
becomes hollow then all kinds of
atrocities become possible we saw that a
couple of years ago in the lead-up to
the Gulf War
we're seeing it now to some extent with
the war drums being beat on the front
pages and the primetime news in terms of
a supposed renewed threat from Iraq of
course there is no such renewed threat
there is a non-proliferation problem in
Iraq and around the world including in
the United States where nuclear tests
continue despite the provisions of that
treaty so that's one example of how
language for instance in the book the
rule of law which is a big phrase that
George Bush has used the rule of law
that's when those who made the rules
lay down the law and it's significant
that George Bush invoked that phrase as
did Dan Quayle in the lead-up to the
Gulf War and also invoked it when Los
Angeles was burning 2 or 3 months ago
but when people do not have an
even-handed application of the law or
even participation in forming it then
it's kind of hollow for them to be
scolded by those in power who claim that
the rule of law has to be upheld of
course it's simply rhetoric that covers
an unequal application of the law and in
that sense we have an unjust use of
language and that is kind of the
mechanism for you might say a propaganda
system that allows these kind of
policies to continue quickly before this
first phone call who then among those
politicians or office holders that we
would recognize would you cite as an
example who makes just use of language
as opposed to the unjust use you just
talked about it's very tough to find
politicians who don't engage in rhetoric
generally when you are lower down in the
hierarchy when you're not in a power
position that has required so many
accommodations to big dollar funders you
can find people who are more plain
speaking for instance when I hear a
speech by Ron Dellums on the floor of
the house I have a feeling that he's in
touch with people's pain and people
suffering he doesn't simply pull out of
his computer an aggregation of buzzwords
and then throw it at people
but that's an exception and of course
there's kind of a glass ceiling when
people talk straight when they talk
about inequity in the society and name
names and name corporations that are
enforcing that inequity
they're not going to rise to the
presidential level to put it mildly New
Brunswick New Jersey is first up go
ahead please in Brunswick New Jersey
you're on the air go ahead yes I'm very
interested in what you think of Bill
Clinton's New Covenant whether you see
that as a philosophically consistent
articulation of a new democratic
philosophy and what sort of rhetorical
air pockets you might see in that well
part of the New Covenant idea is
certainly a religious overtone that is
useful given the kind of constituency
that he's trying to build or the
combination of constituencies but
there's also the undertone of a social
contract that he's trying to make or
remake between the government and the
American people and the rhetoric of the
New Covenant I think goes hand-in-hand
with rhetoric that Clinton and Al Gore
and the Democratic Leadership Council
has been trying to implement for a long
time and if we look at their language
about the need for Responsible behavior
you know responsibility is a big thing
in Bill Clinton's rhetoric and when I
was in Madison Square Garden during the
convention in New York of course that
was in the air a lot with Clinton and
other speakers but the problem with the
responsibilty rhetoric and I certainly
have a lot of mention of responsibility
in the book the problem is that you have
an unequal application of that demand
you've got a record of Bill Clinton
saying that people on welfare should
behave responsibly people who are
getting public assistance of various
types oh the government in that social
contract responsible behavior as kind of
a quid pro quo but there's not that kind
of preaching that goes on towards the
large corporations that for instance
have continued to foul the waterways of
the state of Arkansas so it's a very
unequal application of the term before
the next call and want to continue
throughout the rest of the time to give
people a sample of what's in here and
I'll just read here's one entry picked
at random hardball politics a figure of
speech that can make complaints about
political chicanery seem like they're
coming from naive persons with overly
thin cowhide it was just good old
hardball American politics
is the usage cited from the virginia
republican legislative caucus in 1991
houston texas next go ahead yes few two
questions one do you see such groups is
the anti-defamation league and the nwa
CP performing a valuable service and
kind of demystifying and identifying
divisive code words and two on a
historical note who do you see in recent
presidential history is the best
improvisational speaker thank you well
in terms of divisive code words i think
that divisive can cut both ways as I
recall divisive is in the book unless we
cut it out of the galleys I think it's
there people are accused of being
divisive quite often when they raise
important questions and I think when
power is talked about when the
inequities between rich and poor are
talked about then often they are accused
of divisive Nisour in the case of
economics encouraging class conflict of
course politicians when they are funded
by large corporate donors don't hesitate
to engage in a sense class warfare from
the top down in terms of the tax
policies that they favor but there is a
big prejudice in political politician
language against seeming to advocate for
poor people to get more of a piece of
the pie so that divisive issue I think
cuts both ways because there are ways in
which we have to talk about how
interests are really conflicting on the
other question about how people speak
off the cuff I think your judgment is
the best contemporary contemporaneous
speaker well frankly I think Clinton is
quite good at it and that's one of the
reasons he's endeared himself the
comparison with John Kennedy is being
made and of course Kennedy was great at
that he also had terrific speech writers
of course the realities of his policies
were something else but we were often
Camelot while a lot of things were going
on in terms of counterinsurgency around
the world that couldn't stand the light
of day in terms of an acute look at what
was happening but that comparison
between Clinton and Kennedy is being
encouraged I think in a very conscious
way by the Clinton campaign
divisive is not in the book however
device is and you define it as a tidy
euphemism for a u.s. nuclear bomb next
called Long Beach California go ahead
Long Beach you're on the air go ahead
congratulation on his usual excellent
work
thank you I like to ask the guests on to
buzzwords that I hear often one if he
covers it in in in his book one is the
terminology American people and Family
Values the first one American people to
me it has different implications I think
that politicians use it a lot in a
deceptive kind of a way to say well the
American people think this or the
American people do not think this or are
for this or for that and to me I
personally find it insulting when there
you know somebody else is speaking for
me and number two I like to know if he
defines you know his family values are
defined in his in his book as maybe gay
bashing or just you know like family
extended bashing thank you very much
actually the American people and Family
Values are both in the book I define the
American people as a catch-all way to
generalize about the attitudes interests
and qualities of an entire population
and then the usages they should be
depicted as good spirited perceptive and
blameless also and I think the caller is
quite right it's a way to generalize
about how people are or feel or think
which is usually inaccurate it's very
broad brush as for values I have eight
different forms of values in the book
from 92 yeah well we have American
values and then on down to Western
values it's listed under values comma
American and on and on and family values
of course is in there I define it in the
book as being the positive values
instilled by families but not the
negative ones and I go on to say that in
the usage of Family Values since the
values that actually hold sway and
families vary a great deal politicians
will probably want to use family as
he's the adjective denoting goodness I
think the caller also alludes to a very
key point and that is that the use of
the Family Values rhetoric by the
bush-quayle people and Quayle in
particular has been implicitly an attack
not only on gays and lesbians who are
part of varying family units of equal
validity compared to any other but also
an attack on women who are taking
different roles and it's a not-so-subtle
appeal to those who are threatened by
egalitarian movements of the last few
decades Leesville Louisiana is next go
ahead please you're on the air
I think author's comments on corporate
babble in particular you know I work for
a very large corporation and a lot of
the paperwork and memorandums that come
around are varied I think not quite
deceptive but I think they don't want us
to know everything that's going on you
know and I just like to hear more about
that I haven't read your book and also
I'd like to thank c-span for their
wonderful service thank you by the way
it just out isn't it yeah it's just come
out in the last few weeks it's in most
bookstores
well I think the point about corporate
role in government is very key first
it's one of the big buzz words this year
is big government and it's become very
bipartisan it's in the platform of the
Democrats that they're against big
government well that's a pejorative
that's aimed to put down agencies that
help poor and lower middle income people
and also it's a term that is used to
attack regulatory agencies at the
federal and state and local level that
provide a modicum of regulation of
corporations it's notable that the big
government tag is not applied to an
agency like the Pentagon that spends 300
billion dollars a year and also has huge
lucrative boondoggle contracts for many
corporations who are making a killing
figuratively and in the case of the Gulf
War literally in order to make profits
you define lobbyists here if you refer
to lobbyists in public you should do so
with some evident distaste the lobbyists
who arranged matters such as
contributions to your campaigns
we'll understand that some postured
distance is an order and mutually
advantageous but they wanted your
cooperation not public embraces next
call New York City go ahead please
New York City you're on the air go ahead
yes sir good afternoon I wanted to take
issue with something on mr. Solomon said
a moment ago about Governor Clinton's
new covenant speech and and the idea of
the new covenant I know that he has in
in that idea called for a great
responsibility on the part of welfare
recipients but it's also been my
understanding and in fact I think I've
seen it broadcast on c-span where
Governor Clinton has spoken in front of
a variety of business groups and also
asked for certain sacrifices on their
part for instance those executives
salary said over a million dollars that
that I think at the moment received tax
cuts would no longer receive tax cuts
the same would go for those companies
that closed their American plants and
open overseas in countries where labor
is much cheaper so it seems to me that
he has asked for sacrifices on the part
of a variety of sectors and people and
corporations in particular so be
interested in your comment thank you
part of the problem is the tone and the
repetition I read many speeches by
Clinton in the last year and there's a
boilerplate theme that comes around
again and again which is that the
society is tired of people on welfare
continually continually engaging in
behavior that the society doesn't
approve of and so continued provision of
aid for poor people will have to be
contingent on certain behavior coming
back from them in response of course the
fact that poor people have always been
up against unequal opportunity and that
there's nothing really in the program to
change that terrain through which they
are forced to walk that isn't emphasized
or even mentioned quite often in terms
of the corporations there are some
perhaps fairly token measures being
proposed by Clinton but I don't detect
in his rhetoric
sermonizing preaching tone that makes it
an imperative that we bring corporations
to heal in terms of their tremendous
power over government policymaking
well let me make clear lest I be
understood or misunderstood I think that
Bill Clinton is a better potential
president than what we've gotten for the
last 12 years but that doesn't mean we
should suspend our critical faculties we
need to be clear about what he is who
he's responsible to and it's not the
so-called middle class it's the
corporations that dump millions of
dollars every year into the Democratic
Leadership Council here's an interesting
entry iron curtain the entirety of the
entry reads as follows obsolete
other other obsolete terms in here there
are a few of course the Cold War is
increasingly obsolete as a buzz phrase
but of course new rhetoric is being
resurrected in a sense the new world
order in a sense is a new way of giving
orders to the world even though it's
very much like the old way of giving
orders so I think the need for an enemy
is constant even though the particular
labels may shift from time to time Playa
del Rey California next mr. Soloman two
questions one dealing with your book the
second dealing with you regarding your
book do you think that possibly this
babble of which you speak that I tend to
concur with is what Ross Perot face and
once facing it said if that's the talk
and I don't want to walk the talk and in
effect I don't want to buy into the
program second question is hope you
don't mind a personal question
what institutions do you hold degrees
from what degrees are they have you ever
been married or divorced and have been a
member of the military services well
taking the second one first I'm a
journalist I have been working as a
journalist for 20 years and my degrees
are not formal ones they're as an
independent reporter I've written for
the New York Times and the Los Angeles
Times as an independent writer of a
political analysis so I hope that
responds to their question
no I have not ever been married I have
never been in the military I've never
been called if I had been called during
the Vietnam War I definitely would not
have gone to kill people for the US
government's policies in that part of
the world as for the other question
about Ross Perot I think that while many
people who supported him were very
sincere and we're looking for
straighttalk bras Perot had a very
different orientation I've written
critically in my syndicated column with
Jeff Cohen that appears in the Seattle
Times and San Francisco Examiner and
elsewhere on a weekly basis I've written
critically about Ross Perot well before
he reached his decline in the last
couple of weeks and I think that Perot
had a very good facade of having no
facade but when you scratched the
surface of his just folks talk about
taking out the garbage and cleaning out
the barn he was someone who engaged in a
lot of the same rhetoric that actually
is in my book he talked about for
instance one out of many examples the
need for sacrifice and this is something
that Ronald Reagan talked about ten
years ago about how the American people
needed to sacrifice and I find that
rhetoric again and again in political
speech when a billionaire or even a
millionaire tells me that I've got to
get ready to sacrifice I get nervous and
it's useful to I think look in the book
and see a quote from Ronald Reagan from
ten years ago when he urged us to get
ready to sacrifice that was a lot of
alluded SNL's ago and it was a lot of
tax breaks for the wealthy ago so I'm
very leery about this sacrifice rhetoric
because it all depends on who it is
demanded of sacrifices is defined as
usually the real or exaggerated burdens
shouldered by some to implement policies
that end up at grand izing others in one
of the Ronald Reagan example from 1982 a
national effort entailing sacrifices by
the American people is now underway to
make long overdue improvements in our
military posture next call Augusta Maine
hi we've more or less answered my
question with your last quote I was just
curious
politicians when the outcome of a war
Vietnam the Gulf War whatever is good
towards their political career
immediately claim credit instead of
saying oh they're service people did
this and if it's bad they it's somebody
else's fault shifting blame of course is
a very tried and true political strategy
and there's a lot of language that goes
along with it
what troubles me the most about language
that's used by politicians to whip up
war hysteria is that it's drained of the
the blood of people it's drained of life
it's used as kind of a rhetorical
emotional technique and meanwhile people
are suffering and I would give you one
example which has been not reported very
well in this press in the year after the
Gulf War more than a hundred and fifty
thousand Iraqi children under the age of
five died as a result of the delayed
effects of the u.s. air war on Iraq
that's not reported as an issue and as a
matter of fact there are many quotes in
my book using many buzz words where
politicians have claimed that we are
ennoble by this glorious Gulf War so
that's an example of how when there are
lives being crushed rhetoric is used to
make that seem like a good activity
powerbrokers sometimes reviled but much
more often consulted example this has
been a long and personal campaign a
humbling experience reminding us that
ultimate political influence rests not
with the power brokers but with the
people Jimmy Carter 1976 Charleston
South Carolina go ahead
Charleston me yeah it seems to me that
this book is a thinly veiled attempt to
proselytize people to a certain
political persuasion for instance I was
wondering if the author here has any
buzzword or defiance the bud buzzword
investment that Clinton is fond of using
which seems to me more taxing and
spending and I was wondering just
thank you well actually Texans spend is
in the book you may know that the
Democratic platform of 1992 denounces
tax and spend my book points out that
tax and spend are two activities that
any government has to engage in I don't
know if you as a resident of North
Carolina chose to to vote for Jesse
Helms the last time out my book does
have many entries from Jesse Helms and I
certainly am proud that my book
challenges the kind of bigotry against
poor people against black people and
against gays and lesbians which Jesse
Helms has engaged in and so there's
there's no problem there I certainly am
against that kind of bigoted attitude
you used the word rhetoric a little bit
pejoratively Winston Churchill was proud
of being a rhetorician has the word
changed its meaning I think the word has
somewhat changed its meaning because of
the usage of words I think if you listen
to Shakespeare being performed there's
something beautiful about language if
you read some of the John Kennedy
speeches they're very beautiful but I am
at pains to point out in the book that
you need to compare the music of the
language and the alliteration of it and
the emotion that it summons all that has
to be compared to the policies that are
being implemented by the speaker or
advocated by the speaker such our County
California that I'm hi I'd like you to
comment on liberal and conservative
because they don't mean anything to me
and also like the Republicans whining on
the Congressional floor all the time
about being the minority party whereas
in fact in government nowadays they are
the majority having control over two
branches and just those kind of things
that people take for granted all the
time and don't make any sense at all
anymore and thank you for c-span and I'm
going to run out and buy this book okay
thanks I'll point out before you answer
that your entire entry for the word
cancer
is an sanam sort of for liberal and I'm
gonna look up liberal right now so why
don't you respond to actually I can tell
you that's antonyms sorta for
conservative okay
essentially these buzz phrases liberal
and conservative are of decreasing value
they don't really define what a
politician's positions are they are
labels that are shorthand I don't think
they're very useful and I actually as I
remember again unless we had to cut it
for space towards the end we have a
listing for labels and politicians yeah
here it's defined as concise and mostly
negative tags pinned on politicians
usually by their foes well politicians
make a ritual of denouncing labels but
they never foreclosed the option of
engaging in the use of labels themselves
and if all else fails if you don't like
the labels thrown at you you can accuse
the other politician of being a
compulsive labeler but underneath the
labels we live in a society where people
are are still facing dramatically
unequal opportunities because of their
gender race and so forth and that needs
to be addressed and is there such a
thing as a bleeding-heart conservative
gee i don't know i haven't studied
enough medicine to know whether hearts
really bleed actually there's a quote in
the in the book as i recall from
geraldine ferraro
where she goes out of her way to he says
i am not a bleeding heart a sob sister
geraldine ferraro 1982 and part of that
i think is the political climate that
has been whipped up that makes it seem
bad to be compassionate and of course
politicians say they're compassionate
but it's a term and a an approach to
government that has been de-emphasized
in recent years jacksonville florida is
on the air go ahead yeah i have a
question for the author and that is I've
heard the term homophobia being used
somewhere on the mid 80s it became
popularized and you know for so long
homo sexual activity has not always been
embraced in our society yet the term
homophobia is the word that seems to run
present almost an antagonistic approach
towards those who object homosexual
activity my concern or my question
really is is homophobia a buzzword or is
it a legitimate word that is embraced by
all psychiatrists or mental health
practitioners who recognize it as a true
phobia I can't speak for all
psychologists or mental health
professionals the term homophobia has
come up from the grassroots it's come up
from people who have worked very hard to
challenge the kind of bigotry that has
so long been oppressive to gay men and
lesbians in the society one of the
finest moments I think of Bill Clinton's
acceptance speech in Madison Square
Garden was when he addressed this
question of how Republicans especially
but also many Democrats have tended to
blame them for our problems and as he
pointed out I think in one of his very
finest moments of this entire campaign
it's them the Liberals them the poor
them the gays and we need to get beyond
that that's true divisiveness that's
destructive and it's also I think
antithetical to the kind of society that
needs to be built blame America first
crowd usage when you're sick and tired
of noisy criticisms aimed at government
policies stir this phrase into a
cauldron of vilification example what we
cannot be proud of is the unshaven
shaggy-haired drug culture poor excuses
for Americans wearing their tiny round
wire rim glasses of protesters symbol of
the blame America first crowd out in
front of the White House burning the
American flag
congressman Gerald Solomon January 1991
next call Abilene Texas you're on the
air I have wanted to know what you think
of the new phrase that Clinton and gore
kind of thrown around about taking back
America what do you think that means and
what kind of an audience that's aimed at
do you have any thought caller I'm just
curious what he thinks I'm not really
sure it seems so vague but it's
real catchy and I just wonder what he
thinks about it thank you yeah that's
very catchy you could almost dance to it
as a rhythm take back America Jerry
Brown used it a lot of course in the
last six or eight months and it does
have an appeal I don't feel very good
about that kind of sloganeering for many
people in this country who are being
told to take back America it is absurd
because they never had America if you
talk to African American people they
will with few exceptions I believe tell
you that they have always in this
country and their ancestors have always
been excluded from not only the corridor
of corridors of power but even a fair
shake by any definition poor people have
been excluded from this government and
we can see that in Washington all the
time so the idea that we're supposed to
take back America when essentially we
never had it I think is kind of a
historical to put it mildly another
example a couple of obsolete terms the
red tide he said that it's obsolete
referring to communism I guess and Red's
obsolete except in the Cincinnati area
and among baseball fans generally yeah
of course there's a new term that's been
coined by some politicians they're not
so into attacking Reds but they're
talking now about green ease and the
threat of green ease is apparently being
posed by environmentalists which brings
us to the phrase printed on recycled
paper usage if constituents receiving
your newsletters tend to be
environmentalists or greenies that's my
ad you may want to add quote with soy
ink unquote Seattle is next go ahead
Seattle yeah this is a this is a retired
doctor who has been a Republican all of
his life I actually went to medical
school between 33 and 37 and retired a
few years ago when I became sort of
burned out at any rate I had listened
last week to an interview with mr. Lam
regarding the elitist and the populist
and his observation that both were
necessary for a functioning political
society and that's the that's the
principle thesis they there there was no
dole there was no social security and
when I drove across country in 33 and 34
a California was our bust was frequently
seen on the roads things have changed a
great deal of course within that time
frame
but the responsibilities of the federal
government for anyone except the
retirees of the military and a few
things like that was absent I've become
disenchanted with the programs many of
which were started by President
Roosevelt and I haven't been at all
happy about the last few years so how
would you put all that in the context of
rhetoric speech political language well
in the in that particular thing they I
it's a good question it's legitimate
when I I I'll have to think about it for
just a moment well at the risk of
seeming a little bit like a politician
here I'd like to grab a little thread of
your question and pull on it a lot of
programs that have been implemented over
the past decades to help people have
been attacked as being part of a
tax-and-spend syndrome being attacked as
socialistic of course that was said
about Social Security and then about
Medicare and Medicaid it's now being
said about for instance day care
programs new nutrition programs that
have been suggested for instance are apt
to be attacked as part of a big
government and so forth but underneath
that kind of rhetoric which may appeal
to some people about how we can't have
and spend policies or socialistic
policies is the fact that there are
millions of children in this country who
lack adequate access to nutrition to
healthcare to education their access to
job training and opportunities are
severely limited and all of the hot air
in the world and all of the alliterative
phrases that tell us we shouldn't tax
and spend do nothing for those children
who will be the adults and citizens of
this country when we reach the 21st
century you have nattering nabobs of
negativism in here you know I tried to
limit some of those Agnew isms I have a
few in here Spiro Agnew of course was
great at a lot of that rhetoric and I
think I threw some of those out and kept
some of them a little check it out next
Reston Virginia go ahead please yes
hello I'd like to ask mr. Solomon if he
thinks that recent comments by Dan
Quayle about the cultural elite
especially of New York really are hidden
references and derogatory ones at that
to choose well I think that Dan Quayle
is walking in the footsteps of a former
unqualified vice president Spiro Agnew
well in 1969 in the autumn of that year
attacked the elites and the media elite
and attacked only those media elites
that he opposed in this case Dan Quayle
has several hundred thousand dollars
invested in an Indiana newspaper chain
and he also is supported by or his party
has been supported by many news outlets
and by the way with the exception of
Barry Goldwater in 1932 these so-called
cultural elites that Quayle attacks have
been overwhelmingly endorsing
Republicans most of the daily newspaper
endorsements since FDR almost all except
with Goldwater were for Republicans now
about whether that's an attack on Jews I
don't really think so I think it's more
of an attack on media that are showing
any kind of inclination to challenge the
white house line interesting the phrase
my fellow Americans you call it a canned
portion of instant warmth just heat and
serve
and that's probably a bipartisan usage
isn't it
among definitely a lot of this is
bipartisan language and of course we
have a lot of talk about family and if
you look up family in the book there are
many permutations of how politicians say
that we are all part of the American
family of course that sounds very nice
it sounds very Ozzie and Harriet or Bill
Cosby Show like but what kind of family
would allow some people every night to
go up to the bedroom under cozy blankets
and let other people sleep in cardboard
boxes on street corners we wouldn't have
that kind of family arrangement and call
it healthy and yet this so-called
American family is such that the
rhetoric from politicians is providing a
cover for that kind of inequality when
it comes down to cases
Clearwater Florida is next yes in 1989
William Lutz produced a book called
doublespeak I'm sure you're familiar
with that right and in that in that book
he attacks the misuse of language and
the obfuscation of meaning in areas as
diverse as government business
advertisers etc I was wondering if that
particular publication had any influence
on your book no frankly I intentionally
did not read it until I finished the
book because I didn't want to seem to do
duplicate it and the same goes for
Ambrose Pierce's devil's dictionary but
I have read since then some of lets's
work I think it's terrific the words are
really key one example and they are
often institutionalized the Defense
Department we don't have a Defense
Department we have a military department
we don't have a defense budget 300
billion dollars a year it's military
outlays I say in the in parts of the
book and I've tried to say elsewhere
that when words are repeated endlessly
they become hollow they lose their
meaning and they are tools for
manipulation the cliche is the frequent
enemy of meaning we have to get beyond
the cliches and talk about the lives in
the balance because of government
policies well it used to be the War
Department does the change to defense
would you think that was a good move I
think it was a move that George Orwell
would have understood very well it's a
way to put
on a corpse and it's not only a matter
of who's being killed at the other end
of those weapons but it's also a matter
of what's being done to our society
think what we could do with the kind of
money that's being draft of the
terminology as among the three military
defense or war to describe that
department which do you well I prefer
the military department because that's
what it's all about
okay La Crescenta California last call
go ahead please yes I'm troubled and
confused by the state or that the only
attacks on Hillary Clinton about her not
wanting to stay home and bake cookies is
against the traditional woman now to my
way of understanding my friends the
traditional woman is out working she has
to work in order for the death of the to
make the budget so why do they attack
her as attacking the traditional woman
what is the traditional woman no well
that's one of the problems I think with
the Family Values rhetoric that we've
gotten from the the Quayle team he's
living in kind of a Norman Rockwell
Ozzie and Harriet kind of world we know
partly for very positive reasons because
of feminist movement activities in the
last decades and partly because of the
economy the picturesque or supposedly
picturesque family where one person
stays home and the other parent goes out
to work and that's sufficient for income
that's not a real world portrait